[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Mike Pence and Donald Trump
wasted hundreds of thousands of taxpayer
dollars Sunday on a political stunt
dressed up as a protest against
political stunts it costs thirty
thousand dollars an hour to fly the vice
president's plane Air Force two it costs
untold thousands to accommodate the
traveling entourage it cost thousands
more to redirect traffic and to pull
cops off important assignments and for
the Secret Service for a stunt a cheap
transparent racist divisive stunt the
Trump later boasted was a stunt but what
does it matter to president [ __ ] it's
not his money it's yours and spending it
wasting it losing it deliberately
insulting how hard you worked for it by
throwing away on everything from
propaganda to luxuries that is all this
pathetic excuse for a presidential
administration has turned out to be good
at Pence's stunts cost you and me nearly
a quarter of a million dollars making it
one of the smallest negligent
indefensible wastes of taxpayer money
since this crew from a pirate ship took
over the government in January let's
just add this up let's just add up what
we know they've wasted in May Trump
signed a spending bill that included 119
million dollars just for Secret Service
and to reimburse law enforcement
agencies for money they spent protecting
him while he is in his own private home
whether the one in New York or the one
in Florida instead of being where we pay
him to be the White House 119 million
dollars from Election Day through the
end of last month
CBS reported that the annual March ski
vacation for Eric and Ivanka Trump and
Jared Kushner and their families meant
the Secret Service paid at least 330
thousand more of our dollars so they
could go to Aspen to ski last week USA
Today reported the Secret Service spent
at least 137 thousand dollars just to
rent golf carts from Trump golf courses
for agents assigned to Trump detail to
protect Trump golf carts when Trump went
to see a golf tournament in New Jersey
they had to put
bulletproof glass in the clubhouse from
which he watched you and I paid fifteen
thousand six hundred dollars for that so
he could watch golf every time Trump
goes near a golf course
The Secret Service also rents luxury
portable toilets they had a deal to pay
thirty three hundred bucks for them
apparently
the toilets weren't up to standards a
new deal with a new company costs you
and me fifty three hundred and
sixty-five bucks for them for luxury
portable golf toilets the grift
continues even after he's dead the tax
quote reform unquote Trump proposed it
guts the estate tax the inheritance tax
if Trump isn't lying about how much he's
worth and his 2005 tax returns are any
indicator he just saved himself an
estimated 1 billion one hundred million
dollars in estate taxes according to the
New York Times and we all know his
cabinet has been spending money like
well like people who found bags of cash
on the street the disgraced former
health secretary Tom Price rung up at
least a million dollars quote on private
charters domestically and trips on
military aircraft overseas just since
May before his hands were finally pried
off the piggy bank price apparently
thought he would get away with the
million dollar scam by offering to pay
back 52,000 but the scandal starring the
fittingly named price also featured
cameos by this whack job Kellyanne
Conway instead of flying commercially
she's a White House adviser it's not
like she has a job or something
Conway hitch rides with price so far she
has not answered any questions about how
much more of your money she wasted the
interior secretary Ryan's inky the one
trying to enable oil drilling in the
national parks could have flown home one
day from Las Vegas for $300 instead he
rented a private jet for twelve thousand
three hundred and seventy-five dollars
rented it from an oil executive Zinke
was in Vegas to give a motivational
speech to the new hockey team there that
hockey team is owned by the chairman of
fidelity national whose employees and a
so-so
packs donated just under $200,000 to the
last two congressional campaigns of
secretary ryan's inky the Secretary of
Education Betsy DeVos the one who was
anti public education she pays for her
own plane however from February through
next September we have budgeted 11
million eight hundred and twenty
thousand dollars of our Education
Department money for her protection
detail Betsy DeVos his brother is Eric
Prince the infamous founder of
Blackwater USA he was literally in the
hired mercenary business if any
education secretary ever particularly
his own sister really needed six million
dollars a year worth of protection one
suspects he could have provided it a
little more cheaply to her
then there's Environmental Protection
Agency Chief Scott Pruitt with our money
he's already bought a 25 thousand dollar
phone booth he's reportedly rung up at
least fifty eight thousand dollars more
in private and military flights on our
dime even when the Trump pirates
actually fly commercial they still stick
it to us Veterans Affairs Secretary
David Shulkin went hear the Wimbledon
tennis tournament on a 10-day
taxpayer-funded trip for meetings with
his wife with an official itinerary
showing they spent about half the time
sightseeing and that fricking Wimbledon
and as if they wanted not just to spend
our money but to rub our noses in the
receipts the private plane scandal is so
bad that incredibly it touches the
Secretary of the Treasury and the
Secretary of Transportation
Steve manoosh informally of goldman
sachs asked for a government jet for his
honeymoon to Europe
claiming he needed a flying office his
own Department's inspector general is
already investigating whether he wasted
taxpayer money to fly to Fort Knox so he
could stand atop a building containing
six billion dollars worth of gold and
watch the last Eclipse from there and
the transportation boss Elaine Chao
Mitch McConnell's wife no there's no
nepotism mayor
she has reportedly flaw
Cessnas rented from the Federal Aviation
Administration seven times at a cost of
about five thousand dollars an hour
instead of going on commercial carriers
Chow's spokesperson actually said quote
the secretary is very sensitive to
concerns about appropriate use of
taxpayers funds very sensitive not
sensitive enough to not do it but very
sensitive last December a conservative
lobbyist named Bruce Melman tweeted out
two lists of rich Obama cabinet members
and rich Trump cabinet nominees the nine
Obama officials had a net worth of 497
million 600 thousand dollars the six
Trump officials including DeVos venusian
and price had a net worth of seven
billion six hundred and ninety three
million dollars that's 15 times more
than the Obama people were worth these
are the billionaire's spending our money
so they don't have to mix with us on
planes a vote for Hillary is a vote to
surrender our government said Donald
Trump eleven days before the election to
public corruption graft and cronyism
that threatens the very survival of our
constitutional system at South by that
measure the thievery and greed of trumps
money-grubbing cabinet has already
destroyed our constitutional system
because while some of the waste I've
outlined here may be duplicated this
partial tally of your money taken from
you by Trump and the Trump family and
price and Conway and Zinke and DeVos and
Pruitt and Shulkin and minutia and chow
is 1 billion two hundred and thirty two
million nine hundred and forty three
thousand of your dollars hand it over
resist remove peace probably a wrong
time to try to sell you something but
the new book comes out next Tuesday
please buy it what the hell you're gonna
spend your money on the Trump
administration